five  um freaky right now  but it also puts money in rage  oh  [Music]  oh my god  round three grand finals finally brings  back the demon flight throw tries to  finish the string shanakuma knows what a  sidestep what a whiffer is oh my god oh  my god  joey storm has rage to work with can you  run this faction but you need one they  trade oh my god wait  they get the final round the health oh  two  dancing a little bit down 4-1  oh no break on the ground throw i'm  gonna get the full combo this time what  are you doing what are you trying to  stand up that's not what you do  that's insane oh my  [Music]  shine to the rage strike i'll block  the wall split  munching still swinging for the fence oh  my god he gets the crab oh my god  [Music]  [Music]  you